for Ohio teens face murder charges after
allegedly throwing a sandbag from a
highway overpass the bag hit the car
that Marcus Byrd was riding in last week
on Interstate 75 in Toledo the 22 year
old died from severe head injuries on
Friday
Jericka Duncan is here with more on the
suspects and the dramatic call for help
from the car's driver Jericho good
morning good morning three of the boys
are 14 years old the other is just 13
they had already been charged with
felonious assault but now that the man
hit by the sandbag has died the teens
are being charged with mark Hebert
Marcus Birds murder around 10:00 p.m. a
week ago Tuesday a woman was driving
with her friend marquise Byrd under an
overpass on Interstate 75 in Toledo when
something came crashing through the
passenger side windshield she pulled
over and called 911 police arrested four
juveniles after seeing them leave the
area near the overpass they're accused
of throwing objects off the interstate
bridge it was a sandbag that broke the
windshield and hit Byrd in the passenger
seat he leaves behind a two-year-old son
and was reportedly engaged to be married
the arrests come nearly two months after
a similar incident near Flint Michigan
five teens there are facing charges of
second-degree murder after throwing
rocks off an overpass hitting a vehicle
and killing 32 year-old Kenneth white
meanwhile the four ohio teens are
awaiting confirmation of their next
court date it's not fun and games I mean
people are losing their lives and the
consequence is for these kids I think
it's fun and games in a prank
they're gonna go to prison
prosecutors say given the ages of the
boys 13 and 14 their case will likely
remain in juvenile court in addition to
the murder charges
the boys are facing charges of felony
vehicular vandalism bianna 911
horrifying tarika thank you